- WeeklyVee, what's up?
Episode seven.
If you fuckin' love boats as much as I do,
you're gonna love this episode.
(water rushing)
- If you do not love losing, you lost!
(electronic music)
(rap beat)
- ♪ Big boy cap, pop off, you a liar ♪
♪ Broke nigga swearin'
that it's his year ♪
♪ I don't talk about it, be
about it what I've been on ♪
♪ I've been spendin' big boy
guap since I've been on ♪
- So I'm gonna talk about positivity,
I wanna talk about being yourself,
self-love,
I wanna talk about just
something around there.
You know what I'm saying?
Just so like, when someone
hears it, it's like--
- You know what you're saying?
What you're really saying is,
if you aren't your biggest fan,
if you're not your number one own fan,
you've got no fucking shot.
That's what it is,
like what people don't understand is,
once you cross that chasm for self-esteem,
like once you're about
yourself, you don't give a fuck.
And the key is pro or con.
When you don't hear the cheering,
or the booing, you've won,
because once you're addicted
to the fucking clapping,
then the nay-saying
has got equal leverage.
You know what I mean?
Like, real positivity is with yourself,
not the fucking motivational shit I post,
or your friend that's like bright.
That's great, but that's
only like an injection.
You know what I mean?
You're good for a minute,
but then you go back
to your own place, and until
it's in your own fucking dome?
- Fuck.
Until you're fucking
clapping for yourself,
and I know it's some delusion shit.
Because if you're going
delusional, you've lost.
- [Lil Yachty] Truly.
- Like truly.
Not on some like, "Oh,
you tried, it's okay,"
'cause it's not, 'cause
you're trying to win.
It's finding that balance
between left and right,
pulling from both directions.
But yeah, man, I believe
in that shit so much.
Being your biggest fan
is fucking everything!
But also respecting the
market, the shit we were
talking about earlier, you know?
Like I'm my biggest fan.
I think I'm gonna win every fuckin' time.
But when I don't, I'm
like, "I fuckin' lost."
- What about people-
who do you think about,
like I think nowadays
everyone wants to be famous.
- People like the thought of
it, but it's fuckin' work.
- [Lil Yachty] Oh yeah.
- Like it sounds good on paper.
- Right, and just to hear.
- A hundred percent, it
sounds good on paper.
You know what's funny?
People will say it, and
this is actually back from
the first fuckin' part of
this, people will say it,
but they actually don't
mean it in their head.
Actually, I think more
people hold themselves back
than think they can actually do it.
I think there's more people
that could actually do it.
- Become rich, or famous.
- Or just happy.
Like when I hear "rich and
famous" now, it's funny,
you just said those two words,
and literally in my head,
I'm happy, because you know this now, too.
There's unlimited motherfuckers
who are rich and famous
and are unhappy as fuck, sad as shit.
Money and fame expose you.
They speed up the process.
- Right.
- Period.
If you're happy, you're about
to get real fuckin' happy.
If you're sad, you're about
to get real fuckin' sad.
Mm-hmm, mm-hmm.
- People don't understand that.
You're not guaranteed
happiness with money.
- And you know how it is, I
get these comments constantly.
People like, "Okay, bet,
but I'd rather be crying in my Bentley."
And I laugh at that shit, I'm like,
'cause you don't understand.
Because when you get to that moment,
when you've got a gun in your mouth,
sitting in your fuckin' Bentley,
and with 13 zeroes in your bank account,
you don't give a fuck.
People don't have empathy for
other people, they don't know.
The biggest issue is not
having, like where people get
caught is not having
anything, or having too much.
They're the same side of the coin.
A hundred percent.
Yeah, but back to like,
if you're not positive for yourself,
it's pretty much a wrap.
And the biggest thing I try
to tell people that are like,
when they hear that, they hit me up,
sometimes they get an
interesting view on you,
like, "Yo, you tell me not
to listen to anybody else,
but what if I'm telling
myself I'm a piece of shit?"
And the answer to that
always is, "You aren't.
Somebody put that in your
fuckin' head and you accepted it.
Your pessimistic father
put that in your head.
Your older sister who hates
life put that in your head.
Somebody instilled that
shit in your head."
The second you realize that
you don't hate yourself,
somebody else put that in your head,
the second you start carving
that shit out of your brain,
like some cancer.
- If you are shitting on yourself,
that is not your natural state.
You are not born, or built,
to actually think you fuckin' suck.
You don't.
You've actually parroted-
you know, a parrot?
Like, (imitating a bird),
you know that thing?
You've parroted somebody else's voice.
So many of you, unfortunately,
are in ecosystems
of family members, and
people close to you,
who've built insecurity
in you from the get,
and I am here to fucking take it out.
I am here to take it out.
My friend, you don't fucking suck.
You're fucking awesome.
You need to carve that
shit out of your brain.
- ♪ Got some questions, ♪
I don't got the answers for them, though
♪ Mama told me to be patient ♪
♪ Build it from the
ground until they come ♪
♪ And they will come, we gonna ride ♪
♪ To the sunset until it's time ♪
♪ All in time, all in time ♪
- [Man Offscreen] So I have
a list of notes, three,
a few companies--
- Good.
- [Interviewer] Microsoft.
- Well, I think Microsoft
needs to look back at
what happened with
PlayStation when they went-
excuse me, with Xbox,
when they kind of went
outside of where you expected them to go,
and executed extremely
well, and the way they went,
and I think the acquisition
of LinkedIn was a win,
that's a win I think,
the company's pretty hot.
And so right now, I would be looking at
OTT.
Like, why can't Microsoft be a significant
competitor to Amazon Prime, Hulu,
I think the "M"
is like a huge OTT platform.
They've got plenty of money.
When you own LinkedIn, you
can do a huge CNBC-like
world of just LinkedIn.
When you own Xbox, you can do
a huge original programming
just on esports, so my
hot take for them is,
start an OTT, call it the "M,"
triple down on esports and business,
and I'm sure they own a ton of other shit
that I don't even know,
that would do really well,
and I think it would be
the kind of thing that,
all of a sudden,
think about how it works
with their whole book.
Now they've got the Surface, right,
or things of that nature, now you've got
your "House of Cards,"
you've got your big hit,
and now the original, now
you've got people fuckin' on it,
it's the best series, and
now season two is exclusively
on the Surface, and now
you're using content
to drive your hardware business.
- [Interviewer] IBM.
- So, I only have surface-level
knowledge of Watson,
but Watson feels to me like a true
Alexa and Google Home competitor.
I feel like they could
make a voice device thing,
where they can humanize the Watson,
like making a device
that looks like a face,
"Max Headroom," you might
be too young for that, guys,
but Google it.
And so, for me, IBM's place
is, if Watson's so smart,
why not make the voice device
play, 'cause I think that
will be one of the biggest plays, and
IBM can do to Google and
Microsoft and Amazon and Facebook
what they did to them, with winning voice.
- [Interviewer] Samsung.
- Samsung was so dangerously
close to winning.
I don't think people
understand how much the youth
fucked with them right before
the phone went on fire.
It was right there, and I still
think, deep buried in there,
there is a underlining Gen
Z, the Zoomers, I think,
are very open to embrace a
non-Apple product in the U.S.,
because Apple to them is
the fuckin' establishment.
And I think Samsung has
the most permission,
they did a lot of smart
stuff with KC, and it's that,
I think that they need
to go back to those roots
that I think they got away
from here a little bit,
because they run on defense,
with the phone on fire,
and I think they go on offense.
Like, I would make a
commercial that's like,
"Yo, you think our fuckin'
phone was on fire last time?
We're really on fire now, look at this."
I would literally come out
with something called the
Samsung Fire.
Own your own fuckin' jerk.
Like take, own your own fuckin' jerk.
It's my favorite move in high school.
They're gonna make fun
of you for your braces?
Own it.
They're gonna make fun of you for acne?
Once you take it from them,
you own it, they don't,
and so that's what I
would do if I'm Samsung.
I would literally come out
with the best innovative phone
we could possibly put
out, go "Project Fire,"
and then just fuckin' own
the whole "fire" story.
These are really good ideas.
- [Interviewer] Yeah,
it's really good, love it.
- Jesus.
- [Interviewer] Calvin Klein?
- So, I think fashion brands
need to really think about
collaborations, youth
culture, lot of TikTok,
a lot of finding their
Off-White, their Sean,
their Kendrick,
their Kanye, their Travis
Scott, their Joey Fresh.
They need to find collaborations, because
I don't think just sneakers,
I think there's a crazy
collaboration with Calvin Klein and
a very attractive man and
woman for their underwear,
like we saw with Marky Mark and
Kate Moss back in the day.
I think a real heavy collab, with
whoever the kind of cultural
20-year-old sex symbols are.
But not the way they've done it
for the last eight to 10
years, where it's like,
Bieber or Haley will be
the face of the brand.
No, no, I mean like collab,
where all of a sudden
we've seen the first
innovation on underwear,
like the band is different,
or the pockets are different,
just something neat, that is collabed with
a creative director
that is that person, and
that's what I would probably do.
And I would really focus on
TikTok if I was Calvin Klein.
I think winning youth culture
when you're that kind
of brand is imperative.
If you are a fashion brand
that markets to 30 and under,
you should be spending an uncomfortable
amount of your money on TikTok.
- [Interview] I have one
curious one, like how would you
go about helping Apple not be
perceived as establishment now?
- Innovate, but they haven't done that.
That's my biggest gripe
with their current CEO.
Fuckin' innovate.
- [Interviewer] Yeah.
- Video games, too.
I can't believe Apple's
not a real player in that.
If Jobs was still around, they'd
probably have a standalone
hand-held console that
fuckin' blew everybody's mind.
Like a Switch for the
fuckin' 26-year-olds.
'Cause that's what he fuckin' did.
- Hey guys, this is Eytan
Sugarman, I'm an entrepreneur.
Gary's one of my best
friends for 15 years.
I'm the owner of Made in New York Pizza,
Hunt & Fish Club, White Horse Tavern.
So you're gonna see a
video now of all of us
in Patterson, New Jersey last week.
So Gary and I took a trip out there,
we went to see our friends, DJ Envy,
his partner Cesar Pina, and we took
our friend DJ Clue with us.
Envy and Cesar are doing these
wonderful, wonderful seminars
where they're teaching their community
how to invest in themselves,
how to invest in real estate.
Kind of demystifying the process
of real estate ownership.
So many people seem to think
that it's beyond their grasp
to own their own properties, and to own
their own apartments and their own homes.
And they're really, they're
kind of breaking that myth,
and they're showing people
how ownership is possible,
even with low to medium incomes.
Gary and I found that really
interesting, so did Clue,
and we want to take a trip out there
and see what they're
doing, and take a look at
some of these communities, and see about
maybe investing in these projects,
because it's really interesting to us to
invest in these properties that
provide housing opportunities for people
that are starting out, just
like we did all those years ago.
So we saw a lot of great things.
We're thinking really heavily
about getting into this,
and watch the video.
- For me personally,
with everything I heard,
because I've never been
a conservative investor,
my conservative part of
my life is me, the human,
and my business, and then
investing, I've been actually
a pretty hardcore gambler.
High risk, high reward.
The one thing that has my
attention quite a bit here is,
there's two things.
One is Jersey itself.
Jersey itself, as a Jersey boy, is kind of
on my mind as I'm going
into this next chapter.
And two, I think Jersey's next
when it comes to Brooklyn.
So like, Maplewood got crazy
in the last decade, right?
So one of the things that I'll
be looking for in this process,
besides really trying to
help in any way I can,
actually, this is all a very warm room,
obviously starting the most with them,
is, "Do I think Rutherford
is the next Bushwick?"
Or, which one is it?
Newark is really interesting to me.
The bones of Newark can
hold 600,000 people.
It's at 330.
That's interesting to me.
And then, I just haven't
done the homework, and
obviously you guys have done a lot more.
There's a little part of me that's like,
what makes it fun for me, is
just deciding it's a caucus,
and then just making said caucus live.
- ♪ I need a time out, Hood
Baby don't play around ♪
♪ Come in, air it out, yeah,
with whole hundred rounds ♪
♪ Ooh, my meds out, now
I'm finna spazz out ♪
♪ If that bitch ain't fine
fit take the trash out ♪
♪ Big caddy, ridin' with
wish, rockin' a Patek ♪
♪ These niggas drip jackin' ♪
♪ Freshest here, you casket ready ♪
- You know, 5 a.m., wake up
4:30- what was it, 5 a.m.?
5 a.m. wake up, Atlanta,
and I'll start with Yachty.
Flew in, quick shower,
several calls meetings, went
out to Patterson, New Jersey
on some- shh! -secret shit.
Now going to a meeting with
a potential client's CEO,
got an eight p.m. workout,
Tiloch will try to remind me,
get a little iPhone video for the workout,
and that will be our Monday.
Most people check out
on this Presidents' Day,
I'm just not about that Abraham Lincoln,
George Washington shit.
Can't even say Washington.
Fuckin' work.
(upbeat electronic music)
- But, so you do all these
things for your kids,
you raise them in a better environment
than you were raised in,
you're giving them more things,
and then you see all these
DM's from these kids,
and they actually resent
it when they're teenagers.
- It would make the
majority of people that
are listening right now
that are high net worth
and are paying for kids'
stuff, and for 14 to 25,
it would make them shiver at their core
to know what their kids
actually think of them.
As would if I.
Here's an incredible thing.
This was a very emotional
moment for me yesterday.
I was at the gym yesterday, at 8:30 p.m.,
because I was in Atlanta in the morning,
couldn't do my normal workout.
You know, it's Presidents' Day weekend,
so nobody was in-
8:30 p.m., in the gym
right here in Equinox,
across from my office.
And not a lot of people there.
This big dude, it was really funny,
talk about admiration on both sides.
This huge bulky guy, big butt, big thighs,
he's throwing up 125's, on like arms.
I was like, Jesus.
Anyway, sure enough, I'm
leaving, and he grabs me.
He's like, "Hey, big fan,
just wanted to ask you,
do you have any business,
any job opportunities?"
And before I could say anything, he goes,
"You know, I don't want to lie to you,"
and he looks 27 to me,
which means he's 24 to 32,
he says to me, "I'm in
bodybuilding and fitness,
I've competed, I'm from Spain,
and I don't want to lie to you,
my parents are taking care of me,
and I don't want to do that anymore."
And when I tell you, my heart,
yeah, it meant so much to me.
- [Brandon] He gets it.
- Not only does he get it,
because he was a fan and knew my stuff,
but I am saying and talking about things
that very few people are talking about,
because I'm reading these comments
and I'm making observations
that I don't think are obvious.
Nonetheless, to your question,
these kids resent their
parents and believe
that they can't do anything.
They are 100% zoo animals.
You go take the biggest tiger in the zoo
of any zoo in America right now,
and you put her or him in the wild,
they're dead in a minute.
And that's the children we're raising.
We're taking care of them.
That's what I keep telling hood kids,
like you've got the advantage.
You think that the machine
is suppressing you,
but the Internet flipped it.
Because the Internet doesn't
know our backgrounds.
That just like, if you make
music, if you make content,
if you make T-shirts, they don't know who-
if you're good, there's
nobody stopping you.
The system used to be against
you, now it's reversed.
Now, college, parents,
dad's friend has a job
waiting for the kid, cool,
but as somebody who's been
on the other side of that,
that kid's going nowhere
in that organization.
The kid knows it.
The biggest thing that
parents are delusional to,
is kids know.
- [Brandon] They know they're in the zoo.
- They know they're in the zoo.
And they're mad at the
people that built the zoo,
and the person that built
the zoo is their parents.
(calm hip-hop beat)
- Hi everyone, my name is
Sinan and I'm a project manager
and paid media buyer at Team Gary,
and now I'm gonna show
you what's on my desk.
Let's go.
So this is my corner,
that's Gary's office.
It's generally super
hectic, but I'm gonna show
what's on my desk.
And I wanna start out
with, as a Star Wars geek,
here's my BB-8.
Huge Star Wars guy, as you guys know.
Just pulling from opposite directions,
we have a BB-9E, and a BB-8.
Can't decide if they are
good, you've gotta have both.
Get out of here. (laughs)
Onto the next one, we have this,
I'm a clean guy, as you
can see it's all clean,
so we have this GaryVee
"It's a Mindset Game,"
'cause it is a mindset game,
and you gotta clean your shit.
And this is a fan-made LEGO of me,
with a VaynerMedia sign on it.
I don't know how much
you guys care about me.
I think I have one fan,
I think my mom sent this,
but it looks pretty cool.
And the last part is, I'm
again the health geek,
so this is chlorella.
If I eat something weird,
I don't want to get sick,
so I just bring my chlorella.
If you don't know what
this is, you can DM me.
Last one, again I said
there's a lot of shit
going on around here,
so I gotta close my ears
and, as Gary says,
Jason can play the clip,
"I can't hear you," you gotta play this,
"I can't hear you," so you gotta focus.
(applause)
- Can't hear you.
- And the last part, this is
a very, very important part,
I have my basketball.
So when I'm bored, I
just play around with it,
and I find that when I
move around I can do this.
It's a standing desk, you move around.
If you're bored, you just walk around,
fuck around with Jason, you
say "what's up" to Gary,
and then this is my desk.
And hopefully it's the best desk forever,
episode seven, my lucky number, you know?
Everything that I showed you
is really valuable to me,
so if you're around the office,
please don't steal my shit.
Thank you for having me.
(slow hip hop beat)
♪ I can't lose, I got high-top shoes on ♪
♪ Heard he on the news, yeah,
he's tellin' on his crew ♪
- You can hit me up any time.
Yeah, I mean, he's always 24/7 too.
It's a real pleasure, yeah, yeah.
- And I appreciate y'all
for everything, for real.
- We got the best gig,
he loves this culture more
than breathing, as do I,
and we don't want anything from nobody.
Everyone's like, "Why is this happening?"
Like different people, business
people, even the labels,
they're like, "Why is
everyone fuckin' with you?"
I'm like, "'Cause I don't
want anything from them.
You're trying to sign
them and own their life.
I'm trying to fuckin' put
money and exposure in their pocket.
- Yeah, that's fucked.
- You know?
Like it's not super complicated.
- I was telling him the first time we met,
I was like, "What's your story?"
Record label, and Gary, he was like,
"We don't even want a label."
- Yeah, like listen, if I decide I want to
I won't be scared to
do it, and by the way,
the more love you give,
that by the time we do that,
everyone's gonna want to come,
but I'm not even thinking about that.
Right now we like being agnostic,
that's why 137's so good for us,
because we're about to make that,
like I promise, the Freshman
List, or other shit,
give us 24 months,
everyone's gonna be want-
because that's a scale, 'cause I'm busy,
I don't get to do this that much,
but if you wanna give love,
to keep it up or something,
we got a platform now to do it at scale.
- Hey, a bunch of B-roll,
I'm sure, today's Tuesday?
Yeah, Tuesday, good day
of operational meetings,
not much else to say.
Good day. Good.
(bubble popping)
- So it's five o'clock,
just fuckin' getting ready,
trying not to spill anything.
Now off to LA.
Woke up and had no fuckin' idea
where I was in Bennington,
New York. (sighs)
That's the fuckin' entrepreneur life.
(bubble popping)
Just landed in LA.
Met this super nice dude, said what's up,
now fuckin' working time.
- Vlog, what's good?
Don't have any video person with me,
I'm in LA, in the VaynerMedia offices.
- [Man Offscreen] You need anything?
- No, I'm good.
About to have some meetings,
just had a senior leadership meeting,
at this chairman's board meeting,
just keeping you updated.
Vlog life. What.
- What's up, vlog?
Just had a bunch of meetings in the
LA VaynerMedia office.
Super productive day, operationals,
two hours with the leadership team here,
like four or five other
meet-and-greet kind of meetings,
just some random meetings
with old friends, new friends,
heading to a client thing with
1:37 p.m. and PureWell.com,
for Gallery Media Group, and just excited.
Just kind of living the
entrepreneurial, executive life,
like I do, which is fun, and
I'm really enjoying WeeklyVee.
I really appreciate that
you guys are enjoying it.
I can see that it's bringing
a lot of value to a lot of people.
See a lot of people talking about
getting back on the GaryVee
train, which is a lot of fun.
You're always trying to
eliminate friction from your end user,
and I think WeeklyVee is
bringing a lot of value,
so thank you, and I'll keep doing it.
(restaurant chatter)
- I was going, "Why is
he in shorts?" (laughs)
I'm like, "I'm freezing!"
- Just had a really good meeting with
a bunch of VaynerSports athletes,
and now I'm down in LA
going to a couple meetings,
and then to the airport back to NYC.
- What's up, vlog?
On my way now to Quibi,
the new platform, maybe
you saw the super ads,
or been hearing about it.
Just taking the VaynerX offices,
which are right...
Here.
So, drip going, and heading to
the court in a couple hours.
LA's been productive, kind of managing,
managing my world right
now through email and text,
and phone calls.
I do that quite a bit,
so it's meeting life,
but on the road, instead of in my office.
- All right, just got done
with my Quibi meeting,
I can't tell you shit about it.
Nothing.
I can't tell you anything about it, vlog.
Zero, zero, zero, zero.
(hip hop beat)
- Hey, it's Mike Boyd,
from the Monday to Monday
podcast and playlist, and
what you're about to watch
is a meeting Gary had with
Pink Sweats last week.
- There's a lot of entrepreneurs
who have more money than me,
but I'm the entrepreneur,
I'm your entrepreneur's
favorite entrepreneur,
kind of thing.
And I want the admiration, I
want to bring the most value.
- Yeah.
- Even what we're doing with music stuff.
Every day.
I mean, you must get it,
'cause I'm busy doing a lot of shit,
every day I get three people
meeting with me saying,
"So what are you really
doing, with the music?"
(both laugh)
- You know?
Like everybody thinks
we're up to an album,
everyone thinks we're up
to a movie, a record label,
everybody thinks we're,
I'm like, "Givin' love.
Givin' love to one of the four things
that matter in society," comment.
- That's tight, bro.
- I think so.
And like, I'm an entrepreneur.
Like in 13 years, they're
all like, "Oh shit."
I'm taking my own business,
I'm gonna buy that old
brand and reboot it?
I'm not against it,
but it's definitely not why
I'm sitting here with you.
- Yeah. (laughs)
- You know what I mean?
- [Man Offscreen] I know
a lot of MTV's going to.
- MTV's gonna do a--
- [Man Offscreen] No, they just, I mean,
I thought it was transitioning to--
- No, they're in the worst place.
Let me say it for the first time.
Tell me one 15 to 25-year-old in America
that fucks with MTV heavy.
Find that person.
- [Man Offscreen] I don't
know about the worst place.
Music is a tough place
right now, especially for
magazines, Fader and everything.
- Fuck.
- That's fine.
Just 'cause, that's like
saying, "They suck."
Well, that person sucks, they're like,
"Yeah, that person sucks too." (laughs)
Like, that person, like
RapCaviar's doing just fine.
Like SoundCloud, rappers
are poppin' every day.
- [Man Offscreen] No, most definitely.
- Yeah, you know what I mean?
- [Man Offscreen] Yeah, absolutely.
- I think, for me, it's
that's the kind of brand
that has to do something
like FEMA or Champion,
like where are they at?
Somebody in the next 50
years, whether it's tomorrow
or 31 years from now, is
gonna take it, do it proper.
MTV should be Spotify.
People don't get how that actually works.
You see where I'm going?
MTV should've been Napster.
MTV should've been Spotify.
- But they were stuck, though.
- They were stuck.
I relate.
What do you think happens to artists?
- They get stuck.
And one album in.
- At the airport.
That fuckin' Delta life.
Heading to New York.
Big day tomorrow.
WeeklyVee.
(airplane intercom chattering)
- Taking off.
(upbeat pop music)
- Hey.
All right, got two seconds.
Have you gotten into it yet?
- Nope.
- Okay.
So what we're gonna talk
about a little bit today,
and you guys are without me, is
I really, really need to fix VaynerMedia
to be like Team Gary, and so some of you-
I don't think you're seeing
a lot of smoke on this,
so in the most awesome, safe
way, I'm trying to decide
who in this room needs to go and
be in the creative department at Vayner,
and you need to decide
if that's good for you,
or if you're excited about that,
and so I've already had
subtle conversations with you.
I've already been game planning
on my very ivory tower point of view
of watching you guys from afar.
It's a pretty epic opportunity
from the standpoint,
what you have to kind of decide
is, I'm gonna try to make it
as unbelievable for you as possible,
'cause you're my inner circle, of like,
"Is there value to go in
there for 18 to 24 months?
Is there any option to then come back?"
What I will say is, if you're gonna,
and Andy will go through
and we'll go through it all together,
if you go in, it's gotta
be minimum 12 months.
Like if you go there and it's
a month in, and you're like,
"Fuck, I didn't realize
how awesome it was.
Like I thought I hated Syd but I love Syd.
Like, he's way better than
Rick," that kind of stuff?
So, but I definitely need
to impact the agency,
and the best way for me
to do that is to impact it
with the people that fuckin' know.
And guess what?
You're the people that know.
So, it's not like, if you were
like super pumped about it,
you're not gonna hurt my feelings.
This is all one family.
I'm saying this 'cause I
don't want you to be scared
and be like, "Yeah!"
And be like, "Oh, did Gary win it?"
Like I'm pumped either way,
I think there's a real impact
that all of you can make.
And this is really an important moment.
Vayner's on the cusp, and the
thing that Vayner's missing
is a creative department
that looks like you,
at the "maker" level that goes up.
For a lot of you, I think
this is gonna be a huge opportunity.
A lot of learnings.
We talk like, it's a lot slower
out there than it is here.
You can, the other thing is,
it can lead to a career path
that might be something you want.
Like you guys know, from my perspective,
everybody just needs to
find their happiness.
If their happiness is to
be a creative director
in the number one creative
agency in the world in six years,
and make 290 or 320, then
let me tell you right now,
you'd better really
consider this one right now.
'Cause that's gonna be by far
the easiest path for that.
So really exciting time,
I wanted to jump in
because I didn't want you-
I didn't want somebody else
to deliver the news of like,
"Hey, I'm in a mental place right now
where I'm okay with more
than half of this team
going into the machine,
'cause we need it."
And I think your impact would be enormous,
and I think for 70 percent of that group,
it could be disproportionate,
the right thing to do,
and last night I was thinking like,
let me create a trigger that also,
if they're 50/50, which probably
at some level everyone could be,
what's the trigger of like, "Okay,
12 minimum, most likely 18
months, you can come back
if you want, what does that mean?"
Very fine tape,
no question, there's
probably some pay bump
that comes along with that,
going into the machine,
so that's some real talk too,
and you can have that convo
with me, so that's the gist.
Awesome, cool.
Thanks, Nick.
(slow hip hop beat)
♪ I can't lose, I got high-top shoes on ♪
♪ Heard he on the news, yeah,
he tellin' on his crew ♪
♪ Where the hoes at? I
screw 'em like a screw ♪
♪ Catch my contact, I'm
smokin' exotic, ooh ♪
♪ Leave yo' contact, I'll hit yo' phone ♪
- Good.
That was fun.
- You were fun.
- You know what it is?
I care about people.
I'm comfortable in my environment,
that's how I like to communicate.
Plenty of people get frustrated with me,
of like, "You're
interrupting this and that,"
but I also--
- I don't care.
- I know you don't.
I care about,
so somebody doesn't like the interrupting,
the good news is, like I
said in the podcast today,
there's unlimited options.
I know there's a lot of people
who actually learn this way,
and in that chaos is the breakthrough.
Continue your work.
- Thanks for--
- Thank you.
- It's fuckin' real, bro.
- [Contest Winner] It's a lot to take in.
- You well?
- I'm great.
- Good, man.
- Thank you so much for the opportunity
to come here and tour,
this place is awesome.
- Cool, right?
- Yeah.
Do you have time for a question?
- Real fast, go ahead.
- Yeah, I wrote it down so I
wouldn't take up your time.
So I wanna know, what is the right balance
between spending money on
things you like, versus
giving back to the people
that have impacted your life
or whose lives you'd like to impact?
- You fuckin' make that decision.
- All right.
- It's no different than the coin.
Don't let anybody judge you.
You wanna buy a fuckin' Pirates jersey?
Epic.
You wanna give back to your
aunt 'cause she helped you?
Epic.
There is no wrong call,
there's only your call.
- Yeah, I got it.
- The fact that you
even asked the question
means your intent's in a good place.
You've actually already won that game.
Now take all the opinions
out, and it's over.
- Thank you.
- You're welcome.
- Hey, if you want a bigger challenge
than winning the Super Bowl with the Jets,
please buy the Pirates.
- Pirates? (laughs)
- Please buy the Pirates.
- I gotta go in this meeting.
- Thank you so much.
- You're welcome.
- Want a glove?
- Ah, you're the best, I love it.
So good, the five, everything.
I've never told this story.
I, no question, in the history of my life,
the apex of my athletic
ability is literally baseball.
I actually have to go
to Colonia, New Jersey.
I threw out eight people
in a little league game
and they put a plaque in the clubhouse.
And in high school I went
and it was still there.
I will literally, literally this summer,
the three of us, Louis, Pat,
we'll make some baseball content.
- Yeah, Friday, good week,
gonna have a film person
with me a lot of this week,
super weird, hope this was a
good WeeklyVee for you guys.
It's like, these videos I make for this,
it's kind of like, "I don't
know," like fuckin' work it.
Like I hope that it's showing
how much of an executive
I am at some level,
'cause I think it helps
paint a fuller picture.
I'm thrilled to be a motivational speaker,
entrepreneur, a fuckin' investor,
but like I'm an operator.
And I love that.
And so, it's what I do, all the time.
Always.
- Don't even worry.
Don't apologize.
We're in the studio, we're
with your guy, we're choppin',
we're chillin', we ordered
some chicken wings,
we're feeling delicious.
(intense rock music)